[Music]
what no british spelling of any words
at least add a ue to a word like a good
chap
[Music]
starting your show with five full
seconds of black screen royal coughing
followed by another 20 seconds of
hacking blood into a toilet can we maybe
hold out on the full black lung
experience for at least the first 15
minutes
no really that cough man i don't know
what's going on with him physically but
this has literally made my stomach turn
i have no desire to watch the rest of
this pilot so i suppose we're done here
also this guy is the king right isn't he
duty bound to let people know about this
i haven't seen a world leader shirk
their responsibility to donation this
bad since harrison ford stowed away on
his own plane
doctor who is that and knight companion
of our most noble order
of the garter this is not what i
remember for garter ceremonies
if i'm remembering correctly claire foy
is supposed to be removing a garter from
matt smith's leg with her teeth
and then throwing it to a group of women
to determine who the next queen will be
did no one on this show study their
history
leaving floral shrapnel on the table
whilst you really
smoke you know how i hate it and even
though it's completely commonplace i'm
mentioning it now because the audience
needs to know my thoughts on the subject
as it's important to my father's
eventual death from it
oh look another game of thrones
westworld type introduction with
ponderous close-ups of slowly moving
elementals set to moody music
this is a full minute of absolute piffle
and here's 10 cents for making me sit
through it
i wonder what wolferton is and why it
splashes oh i do hope it's a right
adorable puppy dog and
finds himself unexpectedly taking a dip
in the pond it's
probably just the cold weather right
which is why the streets are covered in
blood every winter even in the 50s this
would have been an insane thing to say
or believe
especially when you're the king it was a
young lady
named sally as if it wasn't impressive
enough that he's tying this tie from the
front with passing attention he also
recites a perfect
limerick i refuse to believe there is
any human that possesses both of those
skills and can perform them
simultaneously
she always spelled with a k that's not
funny that's just poor spelling
and little did he know in that singular
moment he had passed her the gift of
immortality
wow it really is incredible the makeup
job to make him look like churchill here
i can barely even tell that's gary
oldman under there
waiting five seconds and thinking that
makes any difference okay but
why does everyone like winston so much i
mean sure he has a top hat oh i get it
now
it's the top hat as winston these two
step out into the aisle to have a full
conversation at a royal wedding just so
they can statler and waldorf in some
exposition on the political rivalries
the greater portion of this section of
the episode contains him singing a
wedding and the brits
three things not exactly known for their
level of excitement and honestly
i'm not sure how much longer i'll be
able to fight off my impending
monarcholepsy discount maggie smith
hi philip is this wedding still going
on are we really going to sit here
through the entirety of the vows and
it's not even the cool write your own
kind but the boring standard ones
how long does it take to say man and
wife say man
and wife no i swear whispering during a
service my grandmother once whispered
like this during a church service she
looked up at the ceilings which were
painted black and loudly exclaimed good
heavens this is
not a godly color for a church ceiling
i've never seen a black ceiling before
upsetting if you ask me we never
returned to that church to heaven to
host
well damn it now i really do have to
look up historical facts and find out if
the queen was this nervous at her
wedding
ah turns out they're cousins so that's
probably it you overestimate her
you underestimate her yes but does
anyone properly meet her wait
i'm dressed as a man except she wasn't a
nun until two years after this wedding
it's like you don't think we can look up
the actual photos and see she was
wearing blue jeans and a skinner t-shirt
only old boy how many furtive glances
should we have margaret give to pity boy
before the audience gets there hooking
up on the down-low
well bob we got the obvious one at the
ceremony shouldn't that be enough
oh no let's make it her defining
characteristic for the entire episode so
it gets a right proper bounding
yeah you're the boss bob also you said
pounding
saying 12 months instead of just one
tenth of a decade
this eight millimeters position is
poorly centered and aged just so we get
its home movies from the camera that was
gifted earlier if this was in movie film
shouldn't it still look pretty good
also it has text on it did they add that
themselves either way
reading wait they had snapchat the royal
family was way more ahead of the curve
than i remembered i hope the next one is
that tick tock from 1954 where philip
and elizabeth gave themselves those
anime faces
and then got dragged for cultural
appropriation wearing a shirt on topless
rowing team day
my dear husband will soon no longer be
lieutenant mountbatten pronouncing
lieutenant
lieutenant seriously i can handle the
occasional silent p
but i will not stand for the invisible f
i have to say on the list of intricacies
intrigue and inside world of the royals
that i was hoping this show might cover
i don't remember listing watching the
king get his nasty cancer lung removed
in graphic detail
oh and now we're going back to the
walter reed operating theater for even
more lung removal shenanigans
great great who won
who who won the entire first week of
november every four years
what are structural alterations i see
we've reached the oh so important
structural alterations portion of the
shin
winston pronoun games so hard here i
swear it might actually be his kink
suckling your cigar i saw that yeah
because it's pretty obvious i'm honestly
not sure if it's the writing or the
performances but while most of this show
feels prestige
this real-life affair b plot feels like
it's being played out in an episode of
mel royal's place
it's time to give that blockage a name
sir i was always told not to name the
things you don't intend to keep
what situation would lead to this many
people knowing the train was coming this
way
but just now running up to see it maybe
the situation where the cinematographer
wanted a sense of motion and urgency in
his shot like look at these people was
the director like all right extras
you're just
running happy-go-lucky into the yard to
catch a glimpse of the motorcade and
then someone observed but the motorcade
has already passed by
so why are we run damn it oh
philip got the jacket with the nice blue
screen fringe on the outside
very chic the children will be fine
without their parents for months on end
this lover's spat about not being
present for the kids is nice dramatic
tension and all but remember that malta
trip
in the real world philip and elizabeth
didn't even take their kids to that so i
honestly doubt parental negligence was
ever a real conversation between these
two
early morning bagpipers
treating your butler like his name is
alexa i'm not sure that's the correct
address for the king of england
presenting his royal highness also
wouldn't georgey boy know that he's not
actually the king of england there
hasn't been a king of england's in 1707.
i mean it's not like he'd say the king
of great britain and northern ireland in
this situation but he probably would
just go with
the king also also [ __ ] you the crown
for the addition of was philip sporting
slumber lumber when the king woke him to
my growing list of fact-checking google
searches for today
i thought wolves in splash royal
commercials
will be all right my son-in-law's a
naval man well
if i can handle a frigate that is no way
to speak of your future queen
there's a lot of glare coming off that
dome of yours squirrel nuts
do you hear the ding in your head when
you watch movies i hear it all the damn
time
especially around the holidays and i'm
done hiding my damn dings i'm gonna wear
them proudly like a goddamn youtube
grinch if you want to do the same you
can grab this limited edition
monstrosity from our store
mary dingmus everyone by the power
vested in me by my father king edward i
dub thee sir william there he is
mr ebenezer scrooge take me phillip
to my wedded husband to my wedded
husband
to have and to hold boring
and you are the right person for me
but i do have some bad news there is a
bomb at this wedding as well
what your butt your butt is the bomb
what's that what's in the box i can't
believe it
a real gourmet kitchen and i get to
watch
and your little dog too what's this man
i
jack the pumpkin
just a little you didn't smile because
i'm not happy brenda
i'm in day drag and the second question
what is your quest to seek the holy
grail
[Music]